congo holdup is the biggest leak of data
in the history of africa
more than 3.5 million documents of
financial data that comes from a bank
called bgfi
showed the world what's been happening
in congo at this one particular bank in
a way and at a level of detail that
we've never seen before
the sort of over
arching discovery was to show how the
most powerful political family in the
country and its friends
had sort of
tooled up this bank to transfer large
amounts of state funds to themselves
and what we found out in the league had
a lot of very interesting things to say
about the way some of the chinese mining
companies that have come to dominate
this sector in recent years have
operated in the country and in
particular the relationship between them
and the entourage around former
president joseph kabila
laurel kabila was laid to rest a week
after being shot by his own bodyguard in
one of the most bizarre of political
assassinations
he succeeded by his son joseph believed
by many to be under the joseph kabila
was the president of the democratic
republic of congo for almost two decades
he came into power in 2001 as a very
young man he was only 29
he
succeeded his father who had also been
president who was assassinated by a
trusted bodyguard kabila senior had come
to power only a couple of years earlier
in 1997 by marching a rebel army right
across the vastness of congo and
overthrowing a dictator who had been in
power for more than 30 years
but soon after lauren kabila overthrew
mubutu he kind of continued the
kleptocratic ways of mubutu and his
former patrons were wanted in uganda got
angry and
they started another war and this became
what's known as africa's world war and
millions of people died almost all of
congo's neighbors became involved there
is no security
people are plundering
they are
doing what they call village it was
bloody it was long um and it ended up
dividing the country into several slices
with different rebel groups controlling
different parts and different
countries allied to those different
rebel groups
if we were able to reunify the congo we
will be able to do anything else
joseph kabila actually brought that war
to an end in 2003 negotiating a
settlement with all the various
countries that were involved
soon he was eventually elected president
in 2006 and he took over a country that
is one of the richest countries in the
world in terms of natural resources
but its population is one of the poorest
joseph kabila was looking to rebuild the
country rebuild the economy and he
needed cash
he tried to open up
congo's vast and world-class reserves of
copper cobalt gold to international
investors
at the beginning there were plenty of
western companies who showed interests
in investing in and developing these
assets but over time their interest
has dwindled and they've departed partly
because of the unpredictability of
congolese politics partly because of
the reputation of
for corruption in congo
but this isn't to say that there are not
major
western companies there in fact the
biggest producer of cobalt it may well
be the biggest producer of copper
is glencore which is headquartered in
switzerland
however in recent years the trajectory
has been
more and more chinese companies coming
in congo has a very very significant uh
mining industry it's africa's biggest
producer of copper it's by far the
world's biggest producer of cobalt and
say the last 10 to 15 years chinese
companies making the running piling in
with investments
so they've gone from a pretty bit part
player to
the largest producers of both metals in
congo
the deal that really turbo charged the
involvement of chinese mining companies
in the congolese mining sector happened
in 2008
and according to this deal
chinese companies would build three
billion dollars of infrastructure and
also invest an additional 3.2 billion in
a huge copper cobalt mining project
called uh sikhobin
and it would be profits
generated by sales of copper and cobalt
from sikkomin that would pay back both
investments in the infrastructure
and in the mine itself
sikomin is the mining component of what
was known at one point is the deal of
the century basically trading congo's
minerals copper and cobalt for three
billion dollars worth of infrastructure
projects because
congo is in desperate need after years
of war for roads for bridges for schools
and hospitals the chinese started to
provide that
the sickle mean mine or more accurately
mines
are located just outside coal wasey
which is a major mining hub in
southeastern congo
and i've visited the mine several times
it is world class massive you see trucks
that are the size of of a house
and sometimes hundreds of trucks just in
a row a procession coming up and down
the switchbacks of the mine to get the
ore out of the mine and then it goes to
a massive processing plant again world
class that produces copper cathodes and
cobalt which then gets shipped to china
to be
turned into pipes and wiring and car
batteries and all the things that are so
important for the green revolution
there has always been a
quite considerable lack of transparency
around the sickle means project and also
the infrastructure projects that sickle
means is paying for
because sickle means profits are more or
less tax-free
until the debts are all paid off there
is a lot of
irritation and concern within the congo
that this huge mining project
is not really producing any benefit for
congo
in terms of tax revenue and royalty
revenue
so the leak was obtained by
a french anti-corruption organization
called the platform to protect
whistleblowers in africa and the french
investigative news website mediapart and
then it was shared with bloomberg and
with a number of other media outlets and
ngos
throughout the world to comb through
these documents over many many months
we can't disclose this the source of
these documents because it's just not
safe
in the leak there were all kinds of
threads that we could pull
one was that the bank at the heart of
this project which uh is a called bgfi
it's a japanese bank but it's a
pan-african bank uh that has branches
all over africa but also in france as
well
it often partners with
local elites in the countries where it
operates and in the case of congo and a
sister of the president who took a
minority stake in the bank
the amazing thing is that the sister of
the president actually never paid for
her 40 stake in the bank
and one of kabila's brothers francis
salamani became the bank's chief
executive so right from the beginning
of the existence of bgfi banks unit in
congo
it isn't really a stretch to
call it a kabila family company
basically over a six year period this
bank had acted as a conduit
to funnel at least 138 million dollars
in public funds
to companies controlled by the family of
the then president joseph kabila
or
associates of him
that money came from
the congolese central bank it came from
congo's state-owned mining company and
it even came from the agency responsible
for
the upkeep of congo's dire road network
the other thing it allowed us to do for
the first time was show how
major chinese corporations were giving
money to companies that eventually
transferred that money to businesses
that were linked to the kabila family
and associates
one of the key figures of interest in
our research was a chinese businessman
named duwei
and his company congo construction
company which held two accounts in bgfi
banks congolese unit
what's amazing about congo construction
company is that we don't think it's
constructed anything
we've found nothing that they've built
over almost a decade of existence in
congo and yet we found tens of millions
of dollars flowing through their bank
accounts
from
major established chinese companies
through the bgfi bank
to businesses linked to the kabila
family
and duway was born in 1979 but he was in
congo in his early 20s already doing
deals and and doing projects and he
actually worked for siko mean the mine
at the heart of the china congo contract
and then amazingly he switched sides he
switched to the congolese side and
started working with the office that
managed the china congo contract and
soon after that he created a company
with a congolese lawyer
congo construction company
he was also a phd student at the
university of wuhan he published a paper
which was complaining about the tendency
of chinese companies to engage in what
he called unscrupulous means such as
bribery and corruption to win
major infrastructure projects in the
developing world
so
probably the most sort of brazen and
illuminating
way in which uh do way and congo
construction companies role as an
intermediary was demonstrated was in
2016
when sickle mean transferred 25 million
dollars to congo construction company
do we subsequently distributed most of
this money among people associated with
joseph kabila
7.5 million dollars went to a company
controlled by kabila's sister and
kabila's sister-in-law
1.6 million was wired to a company in
the pharaoh islands
that operated a vessel
which was used to transport
animals such as wildebeest zebras
giraffes
to joseph kabila's private nature
reserve just outside kinshasa and
another million dollars was sent to the
director of this company
some of these very large transactions
are questionable simply because they
don't seem to have a legitimate
commercial justification behind them and
joseph kabila is the very very guy who
gave sickle means
the right to develop these very very
lucrative copper and cobalt permits
the money that was supposed to fund
infrastructure for congolese citizen you
know you know took away
and they gone you know money gone to
president cabilla so was it so surprised
because you see the agreement is like
okay we are going to fund the fracture
and definitely understand why we didn't
see unfortunately congo you see so i
think this is really this is really
crazy
thank you for the opportunity
of
having shared your experience
and your wisdom
with me over the last
17 years
basically since 2018
the year before kabila stepped down
which was also the year where bgfi bank
forced out his brother and his sister
from the bank amid accumulating scandals
caused by a smaller leak of information
the year before ever since then uh bgfi
bank has been trying to draw a line
under its association
with
the kabila family
bgfi bank declined to respond to any of
our questions before we began publishing
the results of our investigation they
eventually did
put out a statement on their website
vgfi said that
there had been management issues at the
congo branch of bgfi and that they'd
addressed them years ago
it did however also question why these
documents were leaked and suggested that
maybe those documents some were forged
or inauthentic and they suggested that
they would pursue anyone who leaked
these documents
joseph kavila never responded to
multiple requests from the congo hold up
consortium or bloomberg news about the
allegations that were made through our
investigations some of his associates
did
come out and solid the investigation
suggests that they were inauthentic
suggested that there was some kind of
smear campaign
attacking the former president
[Music]
congo holdups questions or questions
from bloomberg and in fact he seems to
have deleted his whatsapp account
after we bombarded him with questions
about his business dealings in congo
he's no longer in congo
sikomin denied alt allegations
they said that they were fictitious and
made up and that they'd always worked
within the bounds of congolese law and
international law when it comes to good
business practices
i think one of the most interesting
takeaways is is the scale
we're talking about one bank a
relatively modest congolese bank
over a
six or seven year period
and this is only the money that
we can be absolutely sure about that we
can trace to the satisfaction of our
reporting standards
it's really a lot of money especially
when you consider that this is happening
in one of the poorest countries on the
planet
one of the things that kong hold up try
to highlight is that you know there are
different actors
they put you know in person a complex
and complicated you know system with
purpose to steal money without you know
hold up
i don't think so that it was even
impossible for us to definitely
understand you know who played which
rule
it's not a surprise that
there is corruption in congo the
congolese know this better than anyone
they experience it on a daily basis
the difference with the congo hold up
consortium is that we were able to bring
the receipts that has been a boon for
congolese civil society and so there are
a lot of
groups congolese groups that are now
fighting
to hold them accountable
and so that's an exciting development
[Music]
you